[Music]
like 30 minutes of like questioning you
and then thought you know I loved all my
friends 40 to 80 who like look down and
I'm like who do you think created the
structure of these orchids are Robin
Adams yeah yeah you created it so I
understand interesting point you know
exactly how they got there to come and
logan often we have an office here yeah
even the wine thing i wanted to be the
person that they could have pointed to
when they were at a at the French
Laundry and saying for the sommelier
[ __ ] you the most powerful people that
like the people that walk around here
with you know eight figure salaries will
go to a restaurant and crumble in the
face of wine list yeah and I was always
so fascinated by how it's kind of like
art like it's so funny how I look at art
I know nothing about that world but
anytime I even by accident stumble into
it at an event or things that nature I
watch people talk and it is just such an
inner smirk that I have I'm like I know
who you are
its power of around a subjective thing
that's why you know what's funny is the
first time I've ever realizing it's the
same way I feel about commercials and
creative in my advertising world my
biggest problem is there are people who
try to impose their will on something
that's subjective which is exactly what
I didn't like about the wine world [ __ ]
I never really put two and two together
it's and so like parents want to blame
Instagram and social media what they
need to blame is their themselves like
if you didn't micromanage the [ __ ] out
of every hour of every day from 4:00 to
9:00 maybe they would have a chance I
want you to level up what I'm actually
talking about which is why do we get to
have peace and why do we have to get
continuity financially or economically
like why are we not supposed to be a
generation that goes through a Great
Depression thank you nice
see see you guys see ya hello gang
really well hey Alexa thank you very
good Alexa stop I think the bigger
question is what do you want to happen
are you here to be a non-profit social
justice thing do you want to make a
trillion dollars so let's go about a
different way I think too many people go
this route I'm gonna spend two years
building this and then I can go to BMW
or Manchester United or you know booths
and get money from them to be a sponsor
yeah I would argue that you may want to
think about it a different way and you
can get the same money from those people
right now by showing them that you can
do this kind of content and so I think a
lot of people in your position wait and
try to do a business model that's based
on advertising and I think you can start
tomorrow and build a business based on
service do something about it I am being
very thoughtful love it take care guys
love it first of all in general I love
this entire campaign but more
importantly this means a lot to me I'm
gonna completely Rock and thank you so
much for thinking about me and making
this for me how cool is this right
captain optimism this is just a smart
campaign right super smart well that's
why I want to buy brands right because
like for me you know hello it's alright
hi
get out of ten I know I congratulations
morning Instagram mean d-roc walking the
streets of London decided to go live for
like a second or two every morning now
because I know it's morning in the US
and just uh I don't know shoot like I
don't know forty seconds right that'd be
cool right like I suitable forty seconds
of like some good [ __ ] so here's my
forty seconds of good [ __ ] judgement
judgement blows I hate how many people
judge other people without having all
the context every time you [ __ ] judge
you make yourself vulnerable like you
don't [ __ ] know what's going on in
somebody's [ __ ] home you [ __ ]
[ __ ] so stop [ __ ] judging people
when you don't know [ __ ] but most of all
stop judging yourself because when you
stop judging yourself it opens up a
world of possibilities you start doing
real [ __ ] so please stop judging
yourself because guess what I got
breaking news for you everybody else
[ __ ] sucks too I really like this
whole concept of not putting something
dead inside of you like there's
something that really resonates with me
for some reason
animals more so than plants but but
plant like let honestly that's the first
time I've even debated through my mind
like Anna plants like by the way I don't
disagree with that either
I don't know Commerce is a huge part of
where we're going I will remind you one
more time I only have this company to
buy brands
I think patience is one of the great
secret weapons of my success because you
look at your patient because you are in
the long term I'm not very quick right
that's right
micro speed macro patience clouds and
dirt okay so what do you will polish
look at everybody's always trying to
prove the reason I'm patient is I'm not
trying to prove anything to anybody else
but myself and I've my whole life to do
that when you're not patient you're
worried about other people you want to
be successful so your mom was proven
wrong so your brother was proven wrong
so you proved some your doing it for
somebody your lack of page you your lack
of patient you need more money you're
not patient cuz you need more money
because you have to buy BMW so that you
look successful to your classmates not
smart
not smart and so patience goes hand in
hand with being inside your own self I'm
so thankful that I only guide within my
own self otherwise I'd be living my life
in a very different way and I genuinely
think we're just starting and we've been
doing it by selling something people
don't believe in just want to remind
everybody that we are the
fastest-growing agency in this
generation and one of the fastest all
time and we've done it unlike the two or
three others in the history that have
been so great whether it's a widenar or
because they were great or droga they
were great at the craft that they knew
they left and like they came with we
were started by a kid who had a liquor
store and a kid out of college and sold
something nobody wants we today mainly
still sell strategy and execution around
things that most of our clients barely
believe in do you understand how good of
a situation we're in it's the most
thoughtful people are awfully worried
which is good
I got [ __ ] to do and then 17 right
honestly I just feel like the way you
impacted my life no other human being
has I'm so grateful that you wish me Tom
thanks dude and I think so much of what
you've said has come true for me so much
of what I've done for you I wouldn't
have been if I didn't do that and I just
like why did it break through to you
she'll be honest I think no as you say
the whole motivational page
I can shake now and at the end this
interaction to sell something become
quite generic it doesn't work anyway but
with you I was waiting he's gonna say
something
when's when's when's the shoot dropping
over-delivered you gave information that
was so actionable and applicable it just
keep right where it had to and for me I
wasn't used to them like a Miranda of
great people but the information
knowledge she has it's it's really crazy
thank you it feels like I get it so you
were in this pot on your insta story
yeah and I'm not yeah but like oh dude
thank you so what do you do what are you
doing now
is a concentrator it's kind of comedian
what we're gonna go move into now
there's something that my wife and I
discovered years ago that made all of
our dinners far more fun
which is one conversation so I'll start
throw out the first theme which I'll
start brainstorming as we do intros but
we're go into one combo and kind of what
I would I what I've been blown away by
in this format and what you know but I
think some of you if you haven't done it
exactly in the one combo with this size
is there's a lot of IP exchange there's
a lot of value exchange when the mobile
phone came along especially the iPhone
I've basically decided the next biggest
companies in the world we're gonna be
built on top of it which at the time all
of us were professionals for the most
part that was a little far-fetched I
genuinely believed that billion dollar
and even trillion-dollar what I was
projecting at the time companies would
be built as just apps and I think the
waze's and the instagrams and Spotify
have proven that thisis right
I believe that's fun to have you here
Evgeny I believe that the voice platform
is going to be the next one that the
products and services built on top of
the voice devices whether in speaker
form are just native I'm going to be
dramatically bigger than they think in
that and that thinking that I've been
doing for about two years something
incredibly interesting is involved to me
which is holy [ __ ] the only thing that's
going to be left is brand in a world
where there's no friction to make your
buying decision and completely different
than the tool booth that Google was if I
say to my device I need peanut butter
Amazon Google Apple whomever wins the
game or my personal at home game is
going to either send me their private
label peanut butter or they're gonna
charge an awful lot of money in the
affiliate or first result to be the
default peanut butter which means I
better say jiffy or I better not say
shampoo or whatever the hell you want to
and on and on and on and on my question
to you is when not if you are buying an
enormous amount of things through voice
in seven years which brand will you
always say instead of the generic
product what is your favorite brand that
you could never imagine saying for
example I would say cereal I think I
would say limo or black card but what I
say uber I'm I don't even know that's
why I'm throwing it I'm gonna actually
go the other way Anthea I'm gonna set it
to you what is the brand I'm gonna think
about mine because I really don't have
one I'm trying to pick Captain Crunch
cereal well there you go
I would close Captain Crunch cereal but
I will tell you I'm not wearing them but
I would tell you as I obviously and I'm
forcing myself subconsciously to buy a
lot more things on Alexa that I think
I'd normally would have because I'm
curious but I did something that I
didn't think I would do
I bought jeans on Amazon through Alexa
and didn't care what brand came and to
give you the punchline
they were diesel I never bought a pair
of diesel jeans before if you sat here
if we did this a year ago I would have
not thought the jeans was a category I
actually didn't care about and that's
what got me thinking I'm like huh I
would have thought there's like privacy
I love what people say versus what they
do I would have said jeans as a category
I care about I actually think about the
jeans that I buy versus the bottled
water which I definitely would not care
about but yet in my actions I bought
three pairs of jeans because I just
needed them and I went for the
convenience so anything what would
definitely be the brand because you love
your deodorant so much or you know if it
was just one if everything else was
commoditized
what would be the one brand that would
come out of your mouth as Alexa send me
Heineken not beer
[Music]
[Music]